hey thanks for tuning in to another
episode of left to be talk this episode
is brought to you by my fantastic
motorcycle sponsor el cajon Harley the
number one rock and roll Harley dealer
in Southern California also an
incredible sponsor just great people go
out there get yourself a bike they got
the brand new 2017 Harley's on the floor
right now and this weekend starting
Saturday and Sunday they're going to
have the demo fleet there so you can go
down and test right all the different
models with the new motor the 107 and
the 171 14 awesome the new Milwaukee 8
engine I'm in I'm getting one I don't
care i'm going to i got to get one of
these men everybody's going crazy the
new bike has a new brakes new suspension
new motor all kinds of great stuff go
see el cajon and harley they'll hook you
up get a test ride or have you got an
old bike just head down there and get it
tuned up also Harley's doing 1.9
financing on tooth 2016's with no money
down right now no money down doesn't
matter what your credit looks like go
talk to them they're gonna get you
approved el cajon Harley what's up bud I
didn't do it I've been here to try to
sleep and then these I just leave Dean
comes in here with this with this hall
and that's just like I don't even know I
didn't even do I don't even come at me
now once you come at me know come at me
now man i'm so tired right now i just
woke up you know I didn't do [ __ ] man
coming and then I called the police I
call the police for intruders and they
come the next day oh man i mean i i've
been around cocaine I'm not gonna say he
was on it but it looked like he was on
Chrissa round that he was peaking to
death yeah I mean that is cocaine it
feels like to me
I want to know what's in that bag that
throughout if it can't be we'd what who
cares if you get busted with weed you
know throw a duffel bag out a weed it's
like a you got me with we'd just write
me a ticket or whatever or here's my
card get out of here but but man that
was so like I just jokingly through my
glasses across the room like where is he
throwing that so Chris Brown this is
today live as a recording this
late-breaking news lit happened a few
days ago feel listening on the RSS but
like unless he's Superman where the [ __ ]
is he throwing that backpack he's just
like oh just go with this out his window
in his backyard helicopter I know y'all
got this ain't easy Stewart bag out at
the top yeah I mean like like I don't
know like they won't see this that US is
surrounded by cops they got a copter up
there is I'll just throw this out here
it's like he should have just kept it in
the hut yeah and if they find it they
find it if not you know it's like they
would have just came in when where's the
gun looks like a severed head yeah you
know bike is he throwing it like his
neighbor's yard and he's just like Pig
miss ya know Steve's got a better Steve
quipped on your bag of drugs in my house
dude take it back I like funny the next
day rings out yeah I threw some drugs in
the backyard I need that stuff like the
little kid climbing the fence to get his
baseball back yeah Chris Brown's like
climbing Everest fed sorry bag of drugs
it's such a different world man it's
funny because you know this growing up
back in the day like you know there's no
there's no TMZ there's no like camera
phone Facebook lies that all that [ __ ]
you're just [ __ ] use put your drugs
in like a spot and then they came in you
and I don't know what she's talking
about I didn't have no gun and then they
leave yeah but when you start just
[ __ ] screaming young and and they're
probably following me on instagram
though this guy's gone crazy on
instagram right now have a percent yeah
oh man yeah Eddie he's giving us a show
I poor guy thank you Chris Brown for
that excellent huh
the dude seems somewhat talented as a
singer and dancer and has just had a
mess of problems hopefully he gets the
help he needs and can have if not in a
career a normal fulfilling life because
yeah a train wreck while somewhat
entertaining for the day is always
unfortunate and it's just like get your
get your [ __ ] together man this business
no matter what level you are in it well
all businesses yeah can chew you up and
spit you [ __ ] out if you're not
careful and it seems like he's getting
spit the [ __ ] out sago J man you know he
gets away with murder he should have
just disappeared for the rest of his
life on an island in his retirement but
nope he's got to just come around over
and over and out like like I would be
long gone and I mean and my point is a
you know Chris Brandon murderer but I'm
saying once you get in some serious
high-profile trouble and then you're
trying to you know reestablish your you
know your people digging you in the in
you know years later like all right
whatever happened it happened you know
but um you know if it's like bad boy
image I don't know I didn't even know
what I'm saying what I'm trying to say
is like he's on video today gone crazy
the problem is you're addressing it
rationally yeah and it's kind of like
you know I've had the the belief that I
could rob a bank yeah but the and get
away with it you can rob one bank and
get away with it but the problem is the
person that would rob a bank yeah isn't
robbing one bank getting away with it
and the person that's murdering their
ex-wife and her boyfriend lover isn't
like that person isn't then like well
yes pulled it off now yeah this gauntlet
purse let's go buy an island yeah
they're crazy image broken people yeah
yeah it's uh you know it's a TMZ world
out there it really is [ __ ] crazy man
not everybody comes out of their coke
days and gets out of rock and starts
doing comedy you know like that's not
the pac-man well you know uh all the
people the heavy coke and wild party and
all that I was just talking to a guy
coming up on my podcast in a couple
weeks jesse metcalfe uh-huh and you know
him as the gardener on
on Desperate Housewives he's also on
Dallas he was on a soap called passions
but you and we it was like one of the
first guys I met when I moved to ya in
15 years ago and I watched him go from a
normal dude that we went riding
motorcycles and step into just complete
[ __ ] crazy man and he sits down and
talks about it on the podcast coming up
and it just says exactly how it is and
like everybody knows you're 19 20 you
start making crazy money in this town
and everybody says you're great and
there's no manual and a couple lines
blow and next thing you know [ __ ]
years go by and it's a craziness no no
and it's a great episode coming up he's
really honest about it you know and he
just one day said I gotta hit repack
rehab and [ __ ] start over and no one
gives a [ __ ] about you on the way down
now say most people because like you are
great you could be you know pick your
favorite actor Bobby DeNiro whomever
right and I'm not saying these people
have these problems but you could be the
best talent in the world and then when
you start to crash and burn out they'll
find someone else I heard this that I
don't know if it's true just to shoot a
shell you know like next good-looking
dude with a little bit of talent here
okay next to you know that's how it is
you know yeah I've heard and I did not
vet this but I heard there's around
30,000 new actors or people in the
business moving into the Los Angeles
greater los angeles area every month
every mine in there are 30,000 20 to
30,000 leaving Wow just this [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] conveyor belts turn and
burn yeah yeah yeah these guys just fall
off in the new ones come 30,000 I real I
don't know the person who told me it
told me it with a lot of conviction and
the person that I would believe I mean
maybe it's blown up maybe it's maybe
she's dallas but still right i was just
like well [ __ ] that's interesting to say
that because i was just reading you know
what's happened in Chicago right now
it's just unbelievable man it's just
it's insane so that woman got shot in
the crossfire a couple days ago so i'm
reading the statistics murders up there
forty-eight percent
sure but over the weekend 45 people shot
in Chicago not dead but shut 45 people
I'm like wow man is this number real
yeah like 45 it'd be like if you were
just hanging out in Hollywood and on a
friday night 45 people and in Hollywood
were shot I wonder what the stats are
for the greater LA area it's weird
because you know you're able to live in
a life that is relatively shielded like
we've both seen some [ __ ] but we're not
in the [ __ ] like I bet the people in
Chicago that never see any of that
because that's like the life they live
like there I live in a fairly nice part
of LA it's like a part for families kind
of get together whatever its old people
mostly old people uh I mean it's not
quite Dean aged people but like you know
going [ __ ] you can open the old person
joke and then I'm 50 but old me is 30
with two kids that's [ __ ] oh you're
so old to you you've replaced the word
happy with old oh you keep telling
yourself that you can keep telling
yourself that I know you're up at night
following me on it's his [ __ ] know
you're sending me direct messages on
Instagram a beautiful blue portion yeah
I'm not following you were talking to
each other but there is someone in my
neighborhood or Beverly Hills a pic any
neighborhood the neighborhood where you
are listening to this right now that
Tareq that is someone's heroin territory
yeah like someone would kill to defend
that it's crazy and so like in Chicago
the [ __ ] streets of Chicago yeah whoo
I feel for men I feel for them it's uh
that's a that's a bummer uh we travel
everywhere and I just you know I it
seems to me like I travel a lot and I go
to cities in it and it's almost like
delusional because you're at comedy
clubs and you go city's great
everybody's happy because you're in a
comedy club where people are laughing
and having fun you're like yeah this
city's great which is usually in a
pretty cool part of town or bars and hip
restaurants are we all right
so you just have a slight sugar-coated
view of each city that you're in like
yeah I mean unless you go to a salt lake
city like I did that comedy clubs right
in front of the one in the biggest
homeless areas ever I was like wow salt
lake city has some next-level homeless
but also the rough part of salt lake
city is still like pretty nice no I
thought hey I actually have seen [ __ ]
and I was walking from the hotel of the
coma I was like there was just I mean
extreme radical yeah just fighting each
other in the park and [ __ ] wow this is
wild but uh but but my point is we do
get kind of a soft touch of each city
yeah you know even chicago you go do
comedy there a lot you know I I haven't
been there yet but everybody's at gosh
chicago is great but uh you know [ __ ]
man it's it's always some kind of city
every year was Detroit for a while
[ __ ] ripe the street from my house
van eyes was the murder capital of
California a few years back yeah and
eyes I mean it van eyes is really
[ __ ] weird to me because it it just
seems like another world it doesn't seem
like LA at all it just seems like where
are we yeah and it's just all apartments
there's no homes its departments and
strip malls and and it's just gangster
out there yeah it's pretty wild yeah I
can be rough and it's 1454 a one bedroom
alright that's what it's real it's real
ghetto anyone you can it's like oh yeah
5k for a two-bit it's still ridiculous
[ __ ] crazy man you're in the flight
pattern of the Burbank Airport automatic
around one of the most heavy industrial
areas there's trains coming through your
van nuys man Wow ah well I i wanted to
talk a course as i hit you gene Wilder
died yesterday yeah and he's one of
those guys that I really when I think
about comedy i really i really forget
about early influences
my life as far as probably that are
embedded in me that I do that work for
me while I'm doing stand-up that I don't
even realize surely [ __ ] of course I
talk a lot about Sanford and Son and all
in the family and a lot of that timing
of those guys and that kind of joke
writing and that cutting up on each
other Chico and the man yeah welcome
back kotter that kind of stuff but
really man early early comedy for me was
young frankenstein Silver Streak I mean
I worshipped Richard Pryor and gene
wilder and stir crazy blazing saddles
and and I really forgot until yesterday
I I didn't forget how great that stuff
is but out of sight out of mind right
and the first film I looked it up and I
can't even believe if this is real but
Chocolate Factory came out in 71 yeah I
saw it in the theater which means my mom
just dropped me off at the theater cuz i
saw it alone you think yeah i just don't
remember your mom being there no I was
alone i plainly remembered or I was
thinking did I see it a couple years
later on a rerelease but I kept comb and
IMDb to see if it was rereleased cuz
believe it or not this movie didn't do
good i read i was reading a lot of [ __ ]
last night i went down rabbit hole haha
cuz three million to make okay it didn't
do too good when it came out and then it
smashed through the [ __ ] stratosphere
in 1980 with VCRs yeah the rental of
that thing is one of the biggest VCR
tapes rented ever huh which is crazy so
to think in 71 it didn't do that good
you know yeah but I look at this man and
then I realized as I started diving down
this hole what a [ __ ] genius and then
he's married to a serious genius also
get a ranar who I worshipped on Saturday
Night Live you know hey Roseanne and
Adana doing that doing the nightly news
and all her [ __ ] man and it's insane
right well then it's crazy I mean not
that fell apart right yeah I did never
um and then he remarries the she do she
right she dies which is brutal and then
he keep you know it's like how do you
you know there are a lot of tributes to
him and her this past day and I'd love
his life but you know rebuilding
yourself and I think it's interesting to
look at someone that you know he has
such done he did such a good job of
having a positive public image and
seeming like a genuinely positive person
including his diagnosis of Alzheimer's
where he didn't want it to be public
because he said he didn't want there to
be one less smile in the world yeah
Kenny my kids to know yeah like that's
the kind of guy he was and so for
someone like that to bounce back you
know from something as devastating as
you know losing the love of your life
and finding that you can love again I
just think it's so inspirational to look
at him as someone as a beacon of living
your life with an open heart and being
open to new experiences new ideas and
just putting yourself out there like he
easily could have retreated oh and then
nothing record went down a cocaine oh
you know in the 70s just [ __ ] turned
oh you know crazy earth like wonko you
know you said I tell you talk to factory
bombed or didn't do well like he made a
play for that like that was an important
role for him and I could see someone at
going off and then the queers over yeah
this guy just kept fighting and being so
brilliant knowing who he was but also
playing each roll to the top of its
intelligence like he wasn't the comedic
version of Tom Cruise it's not like Oh
Tom Cruise's talk tom cruise is great
yeah but he's Tom Cruise yeah like you
were getting nuanced performances but he
was still very much bringing himself
into the role like master the straight
man so [ __ ] funny it's amazing
because New York Times did a thing on
they said that his timing was the best
and and and and as I look at it you
really learned so much from that stuff
man and ira in each movie I really
remember seeing as I SAT back and
thought I remember seeing young
frankenstein at the drive-ins
yeah and you know is a lie you know and
all the jokes and that thing and and and
it was just unbelievable young
frankenstein I probably saw it like 10
times yeah and then once stir crazy cuz
it stir crazy is so [ __ ] funny man
you can't even believe it and silver
streak you know what was the third one
they did their kind of HR yeah they
tried to react fire it up what was it no
I don't think you're no evil see no evil
pulling that is it yeah that is it yeah
once blind yeah that's it yeah they his
uh it dude I mean this guy is monumental
man in the 70s and to really think about
it's a black guy and a white guy you
know uh like the combo of how tough
those times were in the in the 70s you
know I loved how how they showed him as
great friends you know and and the power
of them together it's just awesome man
you know yeah and it's crazy to because
I think when people think about prior
sometimes you only think about him as a
stand-up yeah and you forget how great
of an actor he was or maybe not a great
actor I don't you know whatever he was
amazing in film so I don't think anyone
was like he deserves an Oscar just but
he'll just so [ __ ] good um and then
gene Wilder who you know you don't think
of as a comedian in the same way not a
stand-up wasn't you know you don't go to
the comedy store and reminisce about the
killer set he used to have all the time
he opened up and killed and these are
two people coming from different avenues
that just clicked so well together on
screen and just apparently I even
Austrian were the best of friends and
very different people to where if you
you know believe the truth of prior
stand up like he saw some [ __ ] yeah yeah
this became best best buddies it's like
a Disney movie like fox and the hound
like two people from different
backgrounds absolutely and then you know
you don't think it's ever going to
happen
again and then you have like Eddie
Murphy and Nick Nolte yeah you know
which is a smash tube which is obviously
an ode to that stuff and I mean but it's
it's crazy and you know I tweeted the
scene where he's walking out of the
Chocolate Factory at the lamp and then
the kane gets stuck and then he falls
into i remembered that so [ __ ]
vividly like exactly the time i saw it
as like whoa it's so dramatic you know
the bells ringing ding ding ding and
then it stops the door opens he comes
walking out and I read a thing last
night which was genius he said I'll only
do this movie because when he went in
for the audition the director was like
oh god that's [ __ ] him he knew right
when he walked in he goes that's Willy
Wonka and remember fact after the
audition when he walked out the guy ran
after him said you're the guy and the
agents are furious cuz they hadn't even
in negotiated how he's gonna kill us for
money but he said look I'll do it only
if the guy can have a limp at the top
yeah and walk with a cane and he's like
if I say no you won't do it goes yeah
and it goes wine it goes because I need
the kids at the top to think that'll set
up the whole time is he lying or is it
true throughout the whole movie because
was that it like a lot his limp and
everything yeah it sets it up at the top
and I was like that's genius said he
even thinks about that at the audition
has he's reading it like oh yeah I'm
gonna limp and I'm gonna have like a
cane and then I'll be totally healthy
trick the kids wild man yeah wow did you
how old are you again I'm 35 so you I
was one of the else part of that VCR
boom yeah I don't know her the first
time I saw it but I know it was kind of
the thing or I don't know if it was
every month that mean it feels like it
was like a regular thing my have a older
brother for years older and he studied
film at University of Texas but it was
you know one of those things that was I
didn't mind watching over and over again
but even when he was young he was like
studying it
for how it blends so well the dark and
scary yeah with the light and funny and
the way it just keeps punching you in
the face with Wonder and on the the rel
doll book of course is a phenomenal
source to keep basing this film off of
talking about Charlie in chocolate
factory but the nuanced performances of
everybody in that film for how how it
just kind of hits you over the head with
Wonder and splendor in one moment in the
next moment you're like get out of there
Yeah right it's basically the Haunted
Mansion kinda like to me it it was I
thought it was real when I was killed oh
yeah i thought you know [ __ ] there's a
chocolate factory and that's where they
make all the candy and here's an amazing
thing i didn't know i think it was a
Quaker Oats uh-huh they paid for part of
the movie huh they were going to put out
the Wonka bar it was supposed to be
charlie and the chocolate factory but
since they have pay they changed the
name to Willy Wonka cuz they had planned
that they were going to put the candy
bar and when it hit the shelves they
they had the mixture wrong and the bars
melted in the stores all the drum all
the way all the time so they sold to
another company after the film was out
and didn't do good and then they created
Willy Wonka candy line that does
everything now it does evan yeah nerds
Oh everybody I [ __ ] love all the
diabetes out there but I loved reading
all about this [ __ ] man like that whole
thing and and the chocolate factory they
built they built that that was real
chocolate in the river and they had a
creamer to it to make it look thicker
and the cream went bad so the set just
stunk like old milk uh-huh and then
everyone got hurt on this video like
where the one girl [ __ ] something
smashed her knee when she went through
the the shoot and you know like a dead
Oompa Loompa to like I know there was
like the dead oh I got a call and wizard
of oz 20 yeah let's grab a call haha I
can't wait to tell you where the
oompa-loompas come from hey what's going
on you're on the air who's calling oh
sweet it's Fabio hunter
Oh No Canada how's it going what's up
Fabio is that your real name oh it is
yeah excellent a good icebreaker with
the ladies before the before getting
hitched you're so Canadian is it oh yeah
bro did I've never met a Fabio there you
go the only one I know is that famous
one from back in the day yeah I know
hair shorter and going grey so why
should kids will do that to you sorry
dude oh yeah see you see spice wiping
the kids are gonna go Greg that's for
all the [ __ ] you're doing to you all
all right you guys done still far dear
yeah you know it's a way to pass the
time and use the stress so hey come in
here pass some time hemant said you
don't go up for burger when you got the
steak at home so oh yeah I love you dude
how are you today man good man just
checking to see when you're coming to
Toronto you know I was supposed to in
Toronto a few weeks ago and yeah I had
ticket yeah and then I got that Allison
changed to her and I called the promoter
and said look I don't want to cancel on
you if we can move the show two weeks
later I won't do the I'll do the Allison
chain store but if you can't i don't
want to screw you over and he said oh no
we're good and i said i took the turn
that he said yeah let's try like later
on it's like wait a minute did you know
like I had my flight everything already
and you know I don't cancel gigs ever so
it was kind of a bummer because he said
yeah I could move it and then he didn't
move it with sucked yeah I was weird i
came back from vacation he sent email
saying that the show was canceled he'll
calm free tickets so I sent them an
email and then never heard back from the
guy yeah you know the money back but
yeah it's just just sucks because it
makes me look bad do you know what I
mean and and and believe me that weekend
in Toronto was the same
out of money is doing the allysin
chaynes thing it wasn't like I went out
on allysin chaynes that got rich it was
the same money but way more work but i
wanted to do alice in chains because
it's like one of my favorite bands of
all time and i thought this would be an
amazing challenge to open for a great
band but you know it wasn't like i just
said this is more money i'm out of there
actually the Toronto gig was you know
like four shows and and the same money
so your honor Oh hopefully we can get
you out here sometime I'll make a deal I
picky I picked up a bunch of shirts at
the lot tip show there so you come down
uh I'll comp ya hips shirt sounds good
and then we'll go to uh aft barbecue
sound good man thanks for calling man
all right rock on got see you buddy so I
was trying to find the I i was having
wrong I know in Wizard of Oz there's
like the dead my skin or whatever I
thought there was something in Chile and
talk the factory to of like some
horrible accident that actually killed
someone but I couldn't find it they shot
it in Germany yeah hey I didn't even
know that like all this time I had no
idea the shell in Germany and the kid
charlie he never acted again he got
offered a five picture deal huh right
after and he goes now I I don't want to
act for a career and became a
veterinarian well hopefully still making
that money I know pretty wild though
right yeah yeah well good for him he
knows what he wanted he did a thing it
was like this isn't for me well he
probably called some of those Brady
Bunch kids if had a miserable they were
I fell into the hole of looking up
everybody from Sound of Music recently
oh yeah thing where they all are and all
those kids and like some kind of stuck
with it and then but like they're never
it's a tough business you know oh look
that one big thing that's you know be
happy with that also how you just get
labeled early I mean still to this day
like they announced the dancing with the
stars couple today and they're like
Marsha Marsha Marsha she's doing it I
guess and imagine that's from the 60s I
know and they still just she's more
yeah yeah how [ __ ] crazy is that I
don't know what's crazier that or
someone that considered himself a
serious candidate for the Republican
presidential nomination Rick Perry like
how and I'm from Texas yeah I can roast
Rick Perry all I want what the [ __ ] man
yeah like at what point I mean he just
has to be I mean I think you've done
politically before that anyway but it's
just a weird world where you're like
almost serious politician I'm gonna
change our country for the better and
I'm gonna do all these great things but
in the meantime look at this hot dance
number of Oakland A's ours it seems
rigged to me too cuz vanilla ice is
doing it and he can dance yeah I mean
that [ __ ] can dance man who know like
what are you doing just throwing in a
[ __ ] guy that's like an robot and
talk blog and you know what I mean I'm
just saying like he grew up like you
know learning dance moves off and on
this season of Dancing with the Stars
she is the lead performer and a San
Francisco Ballet yeah yeah you know it's
amazing is Amber Rose how far she's
taking her 15 minutes I know at all
that's what that's what those shows are
now though it's the weirdest [ __ ]
thing yeah and we as a country gobble it
up I think it's just the ultimate and
this is I'm not sliding anyone that
works on the show I'm glad you have a
living and you're providing for your
family but I think it's just the
ultimate [ __ ] background [ __ ] you
have on end and you work I remember her
yeah then you get a YouTube clip of
vanilla ice messing up during practice
or something that was probably staged I
don't even know who the [ __ ] watching
this you know like when I was young I
thought I thought for sure just old
people watch dancing with stars yet I
mean but no I mean they're I've never
even seen it but when I was young I used
to go to my grandpa's house on on those
Sunday like and they would make me watch
Lawrence Welk haha self [ __ ] old iron
like Sunday Lawrence Welk would be on it
like five on a [ __ ] network channel
yeah Lawrence Welk it would be like an
hour show of this next number is a waltz
from the 20s and then these people would
be dancing and I was like what the [ __ ]
is this and then after that Disney show
would be on ok
be like David Choe do the wonderful
world of Danny or something and that
would be my sunday around five six seven
years old and I still [ __ ] remember
it right now my memories starting to
come back actually little bits of it
yeah cuz as I was thinking last night of
like wait a minute was I [ __ ] six and
saw this thing but then I was like I
don't even remember six and I was like
oh yeah i do cuz i remember where i went
to school and I remember the preschool
right before yes I used to make me try
to eat broccoli you know what I mean I
never forget you that's an inspiration
for a bit yeah yeah yeah exactly i
mauled you some odd years later you owe
them some residuals I do do that viv I
gotta like broccoli yeah yeah but um you
know so my thing is like how could you
be like 25 you were called a hard you
come home like all right dancing with
the stars is on it I think it's what the
[ __ ] are you talking about or a
celebrity-obsessed culture combined with
the fact that you don't want to think
you get home from a hard day or a shitty
day of work and you don't want to watch
night of or you know breaking bad or
whatever it was you just want to turn
your brain off and you have [ __ ] on
in the background and that celebrities
though was it it's gossip celebrity yeah
[ __ ] select it's just those magazine
people on the cover than us and all that
they sell themselves yeah for that
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] cover of that
thing so when you're at the grocery
store you see it that's on the TV show
and then it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
of just [ __ ] it's craziest [ __ ] like I
can't tell you over and over how I'm a
little time you got here on the planet I
know you hear a few minutes in the
[ __ ] grand scheme of things and
you're gonna give a couple hours away to
Dancing with the Stars yeah I mean I
think it is I think there's a lot of
shitty programming out there but at the
same time like a buddy of mine you know
really stands by the idea that a moment
enjoyed is never a moment wasted yeah
and if that gives you pleasure I mean
you're not out there killing someone
doing drugs I get up using your family I
did it it's like part of me is like yeah
yeah yeah but the other item he's like
come on man you're gonna [ __ ] on there's
channels right yeah and and I'm having a
hard time I never watch TV I don't have
TV but I get on the road and I know like
I'm getting ready to pawn up right now
I'm gonna watch that night of time in
Arizona do you watch the finale so I'm
gonna be there um you know seven shows
starting tomorrow night and it's a
hundred nine out in Arizona I'm not
going outside now [ __ ] melanoma world
so immediately I go okay this is what
I'm gonna do yeah because I really need
to watch certain things because it
inspires bits yep so there's seven
million channels and I understand you
want to watch TV maybe that's what you
love watching TV but pick some good [ __ ]
we're over here last week arguing or
like what do we start aah do we start
the strange things or the the hip-hop
one or this one you know yeah and these
guys like now you starts all dancing
with stars I know [ __ ] I know one of my
good friends and in that dread thing
putting stars at the end of it is right
up there with porn star it should be
dancing with people yeah that's what
this show should be called people
dancing dancing with people yeah those
are not stars this is your bed you know
you know the stars Robert De Niro give
him on there and be like holy [ __ ]
dancing with Sir Robert De Niro Sean
Penn Al Pacino Bono these are [ __ ]
stars they can't go anywhere without
someone going holy [ __ ] this guy changed
my life and I get that we like learning
and seeing our people we admire doing
things outside their comfort zone and
I'm thankful that we live in a world now
where the show can exist and people you
know people are big fans of yours or
fans of mine and this show gives them
insight into our lives right that kind
of doorway so I get that and I think
that's really cool but the idea that
like why do I want to watch someone who
can't dance yeah dance yeah first of all
I tweeted like six months ago why are
people still dancing it's not the 20s so
there's cool dancing I know but I'm just
saying I want to watch the cool dance
the other your me you're like I never
made any straight dudes
oh man I love a night out dancing haha
no other gay guy yeah cool that's cruel
you go out dance and I get it and women
love to dance but I never made straight
guys like a [ __ ] Friday night man i
get off work and i got dancing like i
love Saturday Night Fever top five film
ever and I can get back in the 70s you
didn't have any [ __ ] money and stuff
you went to the disco it was [ __ ] hot
that's some cool as [ __ ] I think guys do
I just don't think they say it that way
yeah I think I saying they're like going
to the club yeah that's what they're
doing but most dudes when you go to a
club they're leaning up against the wall
looking at the phone they don't got just
like you know she should be dead soon
and yeltsin the guy just comes down
start in there's a couple dudes that'll
do it cuz they can move like [ __ ]
crazy and they know it's gonna get a can
move like jagger yeah that song we
[ __ ] everyone now it's go ahead haha
but you know what i mean i've never
heard of did gum in it was a mean week
in a dancing yeah well that's my son too
i love being married and I think
weddings are the best and I've never got
this to work so if listener can help
polish this premise that happens to work
here in this conversation yeah I think
weddings are really funny because people
it's like you look forward to it and
this is your day you're getting married
it's a celebration of like you two
coming together as a family and you're
basically planning any [ __ ] party you
want right and the party we plan is the
thing that we never do otherwise to have
fun like no one has ever like hey dude
we got a week off what do you want to do
and like well we're going to get dressed
up and close it's too expensive we're
only gonna wear once in the Sun and the
sub we're gonna dance with a lot of
people we don't like we're gonna have
some people there that we're just not
fond of your own booze into the mix that
I can get a good fight going yeah and
then and there were any cake you know
that dessert we always crave and always
eat and I get that like special
occasions do things otherwise but like
it's this weird party it is never a
party that you ever otherwise do yeah
it's the weirdest thing but get together
it's like those awesome it then like the
next weekend you can be like how do you
want to go out dancing know what would
you want to walk dancing just loved it
lest i buy some dancing and cake
no no I found all gotta watch Dancing
with the Stars are you going out dancing
I gotta watch other people dance I very
much fought against all those things
yeah our wedding we had donuts from
donut friend yeah Allen Park yeah and my
music the music was great everyone loved
it band or of DJ DJ to help all of our
songs we picked yep and two people
complain that there wasn't enough
dancing music to dance to and I was like
but these music [ __ ] rules yeah I
went out the batter yeah yeah I got a
rule I don't go to weddings and I don't
go to funerals okay I've had that
[ __ ] I've gone to many weddings and
every time I'm just [ __ ] so bored so
bored of all the times and if you're
married you're made you're happy and
Aaron just got married I'm not [ __ ]
on that I'm just saying a lot of times
you've known the guy so long you're like
this ain't kind of ass I know this guy I
go out with a [ __ ] Ricans you
know what I mean and then there's all
this time it's gonna be a Saturday but
oh now I got to go to the bachelor party
with them and then the friday-night
dinner and my old weekends taken out and
and then funerals I put it on lockdown
my buddy died of maybe about 10 years
ago and hadn't been to a funeral since
as a kid my grandfather so I did I don't
really you know go to funerals so I go
to this one my buddy not even prepared
for this and open casket and I just
[ __ ] looked right at him and I was
like well this I'm never wiping this out
of my brain right now yeah and it [ __ ]
me up big time man cuz he was all made
up and it was hot and it looked like he
is sweating but he wasn't it was the
makeup kind of melting and I was like
this is [ __ ] yeah you know open casket
how gory is that it's who the [ __ ] says
that was ok back in the day we just have
a dead guy here and you can look at your
buddy I think I don't need to see him
I'm assuming it was too I don't I have
no idea like that no research on this
but I'm assuming it may be to verify
that it's the
perfect oh right like you guys cuz they
keep saying no one saw Jim Morrison you
know I guess just boom he's buried and I
like was it him yeah my weddings I'm
about fifty fifty maybe sixty forty that
I've I enjoyed and that are fun and then
some oh man I thought this is one I
tried it as a story at the storytelling
show at the store it's not quite there
but like I was at one where the brother
was like the best man yeah and he gave
this give a speech at the dinner or
whatever and he looks at the bride and
he goes I just want to let you know I'll
just call her Sarah I just want to let
you know Sarah you took my best friend
for me and I'm never gonna forgive you
oh yeah look we used to have so much fun
and then you came along it was like one
of these things it's funny but it no oh
no no no that games being cool oh he
just comes out mean like that but I
don't know if you realize how mean it
wasn't he ends it with I just love you
I'll call the guy brian i just love you
so much Brian yeah and I'm glad you're
happy but he lost his bro he can be good
but I wish you two never met wow wow
anyway I'll just like 200 razy why
[ __ ] crazy and like no one else
apparently like my table we were kind of
like but no one I feel like we all
looked around and we were like no one's
getting this what are you here and
that's what's going on he's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] yeah oh man it was it was
insane did you see that guy in like
India or something you guys can yahoo at
a couple days ago his wife dies at the
doctor's office and he doesn't have
enough money to like like Cabot or an
ambulance to the house he carries her
two miles back to the hut he carries it
it's just like you and your air on Jim I
origin yeah he's tired he gets on earth
right that's exact that the chair was a
dead wine oh my god and there's a
picture of him and he's just walking
through the village and he's gotta write
up on the
shyona as she's wrapped like a mummy and
I was just like if your wife does and
you don't have like I would just be like
hey man so I don't I don't know what I
can do with her yeah but I mean like
what did he do did he just bring her
home so there's some tradition or
something that and I don't know if this
guy's religious or whatever but I'm sure
there's some traditional things be
honored I honestly think of my wife and
I have talked about it and I think she
thinks I'm joking and maybe I half am
yeah but I do kind of think it's
ridiculous as now in my 30s you know
unfortunately I've had enough loved ones
dies and and Friends of have had loved
ones die yeah and you see like GoFundMe
zand Kickstarter's funeral expenses and
I'm kind of just like when I'm dead when
I die just put me in the garbage can and
wheel me out to the front of us the curb
yeah what the hell do you need me I'm
going a bit about it right now like why
are we still burying people 2016 you're
never visiting them like what are you
doing that's what I say in the bid I say
I say how many people got Goethe
grandparents that are alive here and
some people clapping I go how many times
you see them a year and they like one
second so when they're dead that you're
saying you're gonna go see them more no
yeah we're never go I go by drive by
[ __ ] forest lawn every day it's a
ghost town out there go stab you know I
mean there's no one out there visiting
the dead people and why do you need to
go visit the body yeah what do you think
oh here's where your respects here's or
some bones art do that anywhere I know
anywhere and also if we could put lofts
and [ __ ] up there the Bren would come
down cuz there would be more property so
I like hunter s thompson just got shot
out of a [ __ ] cannon unbelievable
what manner of the way we got a call I
love that [ __ ] I love it hey what's
going on you're on the air who's calling
oh not what Dean and Christian who's
this I uh look exactly made out of Santa
Rosa I was playin side here to you too
Christian oh I see Simon and made a fool
out of myself no you didn't make up lies
in to hear what happened I was like what
the [ __ ] I know iris back to the show if
you guys didn't listen last week he said
hey what's up dating any
yeah and I listen with headphones but my
ears are completely fried from rock I
couldn't understand what you said what
did you actually say i felt like i miss
haiti because she was on your harness I
saw on Instagram that you had a coast
today and it was the young ladies that
did a call of duty and oh oh that show
on a to you and yeah yeah yeah Oh was
that what's your name I invert yeah the
girlfriend the door gets a point and I
won't happen and I felt foolish i'm
actually a huge 20 years Christian well
I appreciate you calling that's more
than I know we talked on Twitter to it's
more than more than kind you didn't need
to do that I thought it was a funny
moment I was just like damn I'm purely a
guest on Dean show this is Dean's world
I'm just here to chew up some minutes oh
yes so when you die what do you have a
directive for what you want down with
your body do you want to be cremated
good I was just watching the just
watching the feed I don't know man
[ __ ] throw me in a fire terminate a
Viking I want to know you know it's
funny when I was young my moms like I
can't want to be creaming and I was
always like oh no I want to be buried
right but my mom says hey I want to be
cremated ok cool now I'm I y'all want to
be cremated and you know those asses i
have the destination weddings I'm going
destination ashes so I was born into
somebody I'm gonna have Lucas her and a
kind spicing a couple other guys hike
half dome and just throw the ashes I've
half dome now I've settled on the
episode so make sure they do do it yeah
and will totally do it by the way that
will not be a photoshop image of have
Leo knife with a stock image of their
last weekend Oh amazing wow did you hi
cap dome and now uh I don't worry
because I if I saw Kellen and then the
next day I was supposed to be
responsible but I didn't I just went to
the assembly and it was amazing well you
can't hi captain now unless you get
ahead tickets because really there was
so many people
so many people every no it's not
expensive it's just you gotta sign up
like six months ahead of time it's like
Alcatraz now weird people just go into
San Francisco i'm gonna go to Alcatraz
ago hey did you get tickets five months
ago to go what I go you aren't going out
hahaha you think everybody's summer
trails to their just actually you're not
even open because there's not enough
Rangers yeah this national parks and
recreation is kind of then I don't know
Bombs done a lot of good but there's
still some parts where people are just
missing out on opportunities that's
probably better to because it's just
getting completely like just I mean so
many people there you know they're
talking about maybe not even letting
cars drive in anymore and I'm not for
that you just go down to El Cajon Harley
get a bike you can go out and into
Yosemite they can get you to have to oh
yeah I tell you I've been around the
world and everybody always asks me yeah
man man you're so lucky been to Europe
and all this I can I go you know what do
you have anything I live in California
ago you know you don't need to go to
Europe you go to Yosemite and and go see
that first why [ __ ] spend 10 grand on
credit cards to go somewhere you're like
oh yeah we saw the Eiffel Tower go
support onion yeah yeah I'm Canyon dude
Oh Cabo San Lucas the backside total
Santa's for a two-hundred-dollar flight
man the captives for us are the redwoods
up north oh I mean all this [ __ ] right
where we live for minimal money man my
dick here in Los Angeles super to go
hike is dear uh-huh I get yeah I can dig
you got to get tickets away in advance
though already backed out oh now did you
did you do any I can did you go up to
the Yosemite Falls no it was a really
quick trip mean some towels or if I
we're set up like going to Sonora and
like just drove through it oh my god
sure steve has like well we're open
center ah so it's really close the
listen to you
some other time 10 I was just like what
I was like what let's get high as [ __ ]
and drive through it and hang out yeah
I'm thinking of writing it is day I'll
fire I think Carly's gonna give me the
new bike to go ride so I'm gonna take
tuesday off next week and just ride up
there I supposed to do it today are they
gonna give you a little sidecar yeah all
right up there with you being really
ugly and I follow it up here is going on
Instagram and stuff like that but I
can't wait i'm just going to ride the
new bike up there and then ride the back
side when you go out the back side
towards the 395 i believe it is to mono
later that's one of the most beautiful
places on earth yeah it really feel it
feels exactly like when people go yeah
when you die and you go to heaven it
looks like this this is what it looks
like as I ride through there every time
I left there's like 17 waterfalls
there's tons of lakes there's no there's
deer there's [ __ ] bear is all this
[ __ ] you're like this is incredible yeah
it really is man well thanks Oregon to
like northeast Oregon oh yeah I've ever
heard of like wallowa county joseph and
if there's Oregon anything like that all
the incredible it's almost like they're
like civilization forgot about these
little towns and it's almost for the
best it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
what we have in America that like I mean
I you know the Grand Canyon Niagara
Falls Zion Yellowstone weeping rocks all
this [ __ ] I've gone all of it most of it
on motorcycles and it's just like I
think that I'd probably be way more of a
lunatic if I didn't do this kind of
stuff once in a wall and just my mind
takes it in goes out yeah yeah we're
[ __ ] ants that's a hand man we are
pieces of [ __ ] rubble dust yeah you
know I'm gonna ride home and see dancing
with stars [ __ ] I on man amber
rose is going for the trophy haha thanks
for calling that I love dancing all
right god damn fine at night man [ __ ]
going out dancing yeah I'll see you man
what the girl anyway it'd be good boys
just marry matter thanks to those very
nice he did not need to do that was uh
yeah let's go yeah that's aw yeah that's
aw where's Rosa rock you know Jamie gray
hidin was that's it yeah you know I know
her too she's a friend of mine but my
brain my brain is stop starting to stop
working well what you did is you replace
that with movies you watched when you
were six years old well I legit like
[ __ ] kind of move pieces yeah it's true
it's like there but it's in long-term
storage and you're just like I I don't
even have the lock for that right now
yeah like her cuz i was sitting around
and I started thinking about like oh
[ __ ] it hi I told this story I I got
some paperwork for my mom a few years
ago and I opened it up and it was just
like in case anything happens to or
whatever and I think my mom will outlive
me mom is like bulletproof yeah i was
looking at his like holy [ __ ] i had a
stepdad i didn't even remember Wow cuz
it was so brief and it was when i was
like five and six yeah maybe seven and i
just think I and as I was looking at the
paperwork so out of sight out of mind
cuz the guy I was barely even
functioning as a human right and my mom
married this guy got married the second
time and I was just kind of like oh yeah
that [ __ ] guy haha like I don't even
remember anything except his name was
Bill yeah and then I saw his last name
and I remembered oh yeah my mom used to
be that last name bill lawrence the
creator of scrubs call that guy all that
get me on the show but it was it it's
weird when you can just sit back for a
minute and and and I quit caffeine like
almost a year ago now and I think
because they say it really helps your
memory and I was like I'm gonna quit it
to do this special and then I didn't do
the special cell should have just kept
drinking yeah yeah but um I
i said i sat down last night I just
started thinking about childhood now is
this kind of like holy [ __ ] has a long
time ago man even your hold 35 even when
you were a kid was a long time ago it
was forever ago and that's what makes I
mean because I'm of that age and people
my age now are making cool [ __ ] like
that I'm curious I think an 18 year old
like stranger things right but I don't
know if they like it the same way that I
did because I'm watching it uh and it's
you know nostalgic for me I'm just like
kids getting on their bicycles and
writing to their friends house and it's
reminding me of yeah growing up like
there's an awesome cool story like
paranormals government [ __ ] with us
whatever like Goonies ask kids doing
cool [ __ ] with like kind of help of big
brothers or whatever but like it's the
it's the cool period piece stuff of
these kids doing this thing that I'm
like and you're seeing that more and
more with people that are my age now
have money and are of the age in
Hollywood in the business to be making
things that they like when they were
kids totally and it's it's it's it's fun
to watch what I'm curious what you know
kids coming up think of that or what's
the next thing like I memory gonna be
like oh the hard drive I got it was like
a size of a cigarette pack and it held
40 billion photo memories gonna be this
[ __ ] thing that's it and they carried
this thing with I mean there's it
something's gonna happen yeah right
laughs it's crazy because oh my
happiness comes from sitting around the
house and going oh [ __ ] I gotta get a
BMX bike I had one when I was in [ __ ]
in yeah a kid and raced BMX boom I gotta
be an X bike blew my one yeah nice oh
yeah I got the UH SC why had the other
one yeah I the big-tire wash yeah so
then this one came at the right one yeah
yeah so I sell in the silver one got the
red one and cuz I realized something the
red ones at 24 inch I've arrived in a
26-inch 26-inch fits me great but the
big tires as fun as they are and cool
and stuff the bikes slow yeah cuz how
big the tires aren't right holy [ __ ] i
get on the 24 inch I almost was a little
like oh man I could get hurt
I swear to God I was alright a
motorcycle and I was thinking well I
could get hurt on this thing cuz it's
[ __ ] fast yeah and hey I mean I was
cooking down and I go oh man I'm gonna
wait [ __ ] fast it's got tough wheels
yeah and the rear brake uh-uh it doesn't
work as good as the disc brakes on the
other bike right and I'm thinking the
other bikes really what I should ride
man it's kind of slow disparate yeah I
couldn't wheelie the other bike or
anything I follow SC racing on Instagram
these guys are [ __ ] killer they're
wheeling him to riding them up but they
were here the rocky stairs yeah yeah I
came [ __ ] riding you guys can watch
this on Instagram se racing he comes
riding as fast as he can he's like got
25 years old he hits the [ __ ] rocky
stairs upwards I don't even know how he
does it doesn't go over the bars he just
want a little oh and rode all the way at
the rocky stairs yeah it's [ __ ]
killer then he turns around anyone
wheels it down the [ __ ] stairs and as
like that guy's bad so I'm not trying to
just get really on it yeah I can't get
the thing up it's so [ __ ] heavy
that's all I like I used to be very good
in line and it's like a bit he's like a
10-minute bit on my album moment in time
like talking about a real story where
because that same thing it's like you
see this stuff and a guy reached out and
I got a dope pair of free skate skate
park not far from me and I'm like yeah
yeah yeah I can't do that Stephanie no
but I watched the stuff like some of the
the razor team and for in line it's a
lot of kids out of Europe now a lot of
kids in Russia and it's like I was
really good when I was doing it but the
sport has not stopped it's gone under
grinds easy to make jokes about in line
but that sport it is insane how smooth
they are everything is spun in and out
of and I'm watching it on just like [ __ ]
it's and like this guy just bombing on a
BMX bike up [ __ ] stairs that you got
to see that in the 80s it was an
accomplishment to run up the stairs oh
yeah it's like on a 24-inch firms like
[ __ ] wailing it man and then he did
the way spins around then one wheels it
down I was like well I'm hooked on this
se site and and I gotta tell us see
racing is [ __ ] killing it with the
bicycles right now
I mean this way I just got the 24-inch
flowable flower red with the [ __ ]
black tough wheels and I just love this
bike matter of fact I had a podcast
guest in my house yesterday and he was
like wow haha cool it's like a piece of
art yeah and anyone in their late 30s up
to 55 when they see a BMX bike it stops
him in their tracks you know it's just
like oh wow what did you ride growing up
I will I wrote a few different bikes I
had this exact bike that I'm riding
right now yeah but it was a mini PK cuz
I was like a small kid I rode the small
they made a mini one and then uh and
then I raced red line I was red line
with pistol petes and rock shox what a
great red line ditch the rock shox cuz
they were too [ __ ] heavy but when
they hit they were so nice oh yeah I see
guys with that now yeah hey um I go you
know I got it man you won't get carpal
yeah oh yeah yeah because I'm not that
like Ryan I go off [ __ ] man but I'm
really getting into riding man and and
and just all over the neighborhood ever
ride GT I didn't write GT and I didn't
ride that East Coast company that
everybody road oh I forget the name it
was more the east coast bike in all the
jersey guys I forgot it was a high-end
bike but you know uh west coast yet like
the high-end would be like cook brothers
uh you know uh red line I was in Texas
it was red like for me there are GT kids
or red line kits and I was hardcore red
line beautiful beautiful bikes I
remember there is this shitty like
shitty brand called Murray yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh so I raced BMX and you want
to talk about boolean yeah yeah and [ __ ]
talking and roast it and stuff you go to
a BMX track at like eight or nine years
old and listen to some of the [ __ ]
coming out of kids mouth so whenever
when it like we were poor as [ __ ] all
the guys that I rode with my four
friends we had no money but we had the
best [ __ ] bikes and we didn't steal
more anything it was just like I worked
at a bike shop on the weekends for free
and a guy so and then we laid a row
for a team panda and they gave us primo
primo bikes so you'd go to the track and
a kid would show up with Marie and and
and there would be two things it would
be like oh [ __ ] team Marita meaning like
you know like in life we would use it
like out at the movies a kid would show
up with like fake vans it like total
team Murr you know what I mean like what
a Murray then we shorten it like fool
Murray and yeah it's a skateboarding it
was Hobie yeah it was sold by toys r us
I think exactly is all these [ __ ] fake
like Marla sold at Kmart you know what I
mean and then we would call them squids
too huh what a [ __ ] squid man you
know like you're going you're coming out
of gate for the first jump and some
squid with like you know cut catch your
[ __ ] pedal and you'd go down you
might [ __ ] sad hahaha so that's some
more [ __ ] childhood flashbacks man
teen Murray your [ __ ] Murray I'm
gonna start saying that around the
comedy cuz that guy's I'm Murray hahaha
cuz the word that there were at one time
there was men named Marie oh sure right
yeah yeah my name's Marie it's like you
can change that you're an adult change
your name what what I changed my
granddad's name and he named a bike line
after it Marie my my grandfather's name
was Claude like dirt clod Claude sure
and my grandmother's name was Mildred
well it's gonna be the same way [ __ ]
old names my wife's name is Amanda and
it's like still kind of common but like
when we were born like everyone was
[ __ ] named Amanda yeah I don't know
too many Dean's yeah oh that's an old
name you know like it's an old name also
Fred that's an old [ __ ] name Frank
Frank my quiz how you had me yeah
goddamn that shit's funny jerky boys
let's get out of here dr. you got coming
up oh dear i should I'm so bad at this I
should be prepared just follow me on
twitter at Spicer if you want to talk
video games I do a video game show
called DLC confided at five by five TV /
DLC i'm headed to uh let's see tomorrow
or today if you're listening to this on
the
feed i will be at arizona all weekend
labor day weekend at the house of comedy
headlining and then I'm going on the
road with bill burr and it's going to be
[ __ ] killer I think it's two three
nights North Carolina Durham get tickets
right now some theater there oh the
Durham theatre i think it's called and
let's see what all in edmonton i'm
coming out your way and into September
edmonton canada be headlining out there
and monday i'll let the be talk rich
robinson from the black crowes do not
miss that it is a [ __ ] smoke in
episode i spent a whole day with him
yesterday all day and it was Wow when
you hang out with one a guy that you
worshipped it is so [ __ ] weird and
and really hard to podcasts suddenly
like when i had Jerry on from devo or
dave meniketti from wine tea when a guy
comes in as I Connacht is rich robinson
to me who wrote so many songs and and
I've got 25 years of questions haha I
think it's the hardest shows to do for
me because my brain is [ __ ] cooking I
only had about an hour because he was
playing the Grammy Museum which I went
to after yeah and by the way I might
shoot my special at the growing up in
theater I was in there holds about 50 oh
it's awesome I think do two shows in
there and what gave me the idea is doing
a Q&A in there and I could hear the
laughs in there yeah and it's this
[ __ ] cool mini theatre beautiful and
it's right down that's all a picture
like the red curtains or whatever that's
great this is a [ __ ] spot man and
they got different curtains like if you
want boobs oh nice Lou whatever anyways
so monday I kept it together I'm not
like a fanboy it's not like that like oh
my god I can't leave you here that's
never me it's more like holy [ __ ] where
do I start right where do I go cuz as
he's talking my brains going like [ __ ]
asked him this Esther day you know you
gotta sit back listen to what he's
saying and then ask the next question
but he's triggering questions in my
as he's going I'm going oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what I mean it's like
so anyway monday check it out and thanks
for tuning in leave a review and
subscribe to let the B talk see you guys